Always Sunny in Philadelphia we both did
the first season you did the pilot I
I did Glenn in college we were what he
told me about the show when him and Rob
were and Charlie were like creating this
and this is what I mean about guys and
girls
I wouldn't think to do that I was 22 and
I was like I what am I going to do
between auditions like I have to wait
for somebody to call me and send me an
audition these guys were out there
making that was such a huge lesson
to me watching them go through that
process so I was not even in the pilot I
was in the
I had a great time and then seeing it
later I was like yeah of course it's
their humor it's hilarious like it is
who they are and they
they did it all by themselves it comes
to show you folks that
you can do it yourself especially
nowadays with the iPhone oh my God and
we talk about it all the time and should
more important you should just go shoot
everything I should be going to do that